ce phénomène cyclique commence quand les
eaux chaudes de l'océan Pacifique
occidental tropicales se déplace vers
l'est le long de l'équateur en direction
des côtes d'Amérique du Sud
les eaux de surface chaude du Pacifique
restent alors près des côtes
[Musique]
l'augmentation de ces températures dans
l'est du bassin Pacifique décale
l'activité des pluies dans l'est du
bassin donc donne des anomalies de pluie
et peut donner des événements très
pluvieux accompagnés d'inondations sur
la côte est de l'Amérique du Sud
[Musique]
début janvier à assuncione les crues ont
contraint plus de 150 000 personnes à
abandonner leur foyer
à différents endroits la capitale a
connu de graves inondations depuis le
mois de novembre
à la mi-décembre le niveau du fleuve
Paraguay avait déjà atteint 6 mètres 50
sont plus haut niveau de toute l'année
largement supérieur au seuil déjà
critique de 5 mètres 50
beaucoup redoutaient le pire
des milliers de personnes ont été
évacuées des quartiers situés le long de
la rivière quand le niveau du fleuve a
atteint les 7 mètres 84 le 7 janvier
chaque fois la crue est plus intense
c'est un lieu où le fleuve grandit sans
cesse
et dernièrement il est devenu
incontrôlable
je n'ai pas pu venir jusqu'ici
aujourd'hui j'ai fait un effort pour
venir pour mon père
vous voyez ce n'est pas facile d'accès
mon père a toute sa vie ici ces animaux
sa famille il ne veut pas partir
près de 6000 familles ont été touchés
dans les premières semaines de décembre
après que le niveau du fleuve a franchi
la barre des 7 mètres le nombre des
victimes à doubler
13000 familles furent victimes des
inondations la plupart d'entre elles
originaire de Los bagnatos le quartier
pauvre de la ville situé tout proche du
fleuve
[Musique]
le gouvernement paraguayen déclara
l'état d'urgence à assuncian ainsi que
dans cet autre région du pays par
élément affecté
le phénomène El Nino se produit de
manière aléatoire à peu près tous les
deux à 7 ans et dure de 12 à 18 mois
engendrant des risques répétés
d'inondation dans les zones exposées et
la menace d'épidémie de choléra et de
paludisme
elle est d'abord montée petit à petit et
puis c'est venu d'un coup
ça s'est passé comme ça en 64 ou 75
cette année nous avons été inondé deux
fois l'eau est montée jusqu'au mur la
marque est arrivée quasiment à 9 mètres
nous sommes prêts à rester parce que
j'aime ma vie ici le problème c'est la
salle de bain la lumière et les maladies
pas moins de 200 pilonnes électriques
ont été détruits par les pluies
torrentiels laissant des milliers de
foyers sans électricité
quatre personnes ont trouvé la mort
victime de chute d'arbres dans ce qui
fut considéré comme les pires
inondations depuis un demi-siècle
[Musique]
le montant total des dégâts est estimé à
3,5 millions de dollars
[Musique]